okay okay it's your boy cyka here with
kanye west right here and we are doing
the first mission of the new though in
that yeah Who am I sitting it's not it's
not a new one it's like old world blues
the expansion pack and this is the one
they get there to the new plan midnight
science fiction theater feature so we're
doing this with it was a little bit of
the walk but you know [ __ ] it you know
live once you know like countless lives
six times but he's right she sure as
[ __ ] i canna miles are gonna set up shut
bandits I hate their yes the no oh shut
ya better gun huh let's see here let's
say here huh dynamite throwing spear you
know I'm just like yeah it becomes that
way you know he's probably gonna say me
so yeah hook it hello up can you serve a
[ __ ] can he is aiming yeah a wolf's are
very funny creatures you know because it
turns out like no matter how much bacon
you give a wolf they will never love you
and you know i know i saw this blog and
it was like uh hello sorry and I just
kept giving at bay get more more bacon
and you know I didn't attack an attack
is fine I kept shoving bacon eventually
I think maybe give it too much big get
me Kelly look like you're getting sick
after a while but you know dogs they
just keep on eating anyway I kept giving
at this bacon it as oh oh I think that's
given a bake him like too fast and he
was like gagging I stopped a little bit
at some point actually ran out of bacon
again with some pancake makes it all
that but this [ __ ] hello sorry what do
you know just hanging out here howdy
haha day hey there hey okay anyway I you
know when I ran out of pancake mix I
thought like oh for sure this awful
loves me like i damned it I domesticated
I've done
hundreds of years of work be really fast
because I had this great pancake mix
well and it turns out now he wanted more
and he chased me but you know um I have
to say like yeah a little sickly you
better get out of here hello iconic ah
hey search him I'll take that as a yes
I'll take this I'll tagged us okay my
way bets I can't i'ma um got good good
good okay and well anyways um yeah so he
was a little sickly but he still chased
after me go to enthrall baking at him I
went back to check the next day and he
was gone I don't know what happened
Talia the [ __ ] is this tossed a [ __ ] out
yeah that's for sure yeah ma'am um [ __ ]
is that over there that is [ __ ]
disgusting I am fine with that [ __ ] Adam
lands
why don't you sing I take a sip what the
[ __ ] that about like okay it's fine yeah
hey uh yeah I get old something so prove
it trust us can I trust this one back
you know Kanye does not trust this [ __ ]
okay okay hello man it's our second when
I guess not [ __ ] are those two huge
things over there [ __ ] getting kind of
close to the ants psychobabble does not
like an so let me tell you about Jose
okay that's good what's that black smoke
call it cut that [ __ ] out you know I see
smoke if it's not coming from panties
which it usually is I get the [ __ ] away
okay I don't waste time with not
sweating panics ok let's go down here
that's going on here [ __ ] farrowing
our clothes our clothes
oh [ __ ] solace not yet yeah that's a
stretch what the [ __ ] man air couldn't
you just drink it like booze what
lottery only lottery them hey all right
you how did it but not no more powder
get by what the [ __ ] okay
hmm nice things out here that can get
married cause
hmm that's how they shot their robot
what what's the things moving
shut Oh can't wait till midnight eyebrow
hmm
cuz they gotta pop this fool my [ __ ]
god who the [ __ ] is going on here I'm
just gonna back up until it fades away
okay um one hour oh ok
what
ah Shep and I guess I okay how old world
bless this is interesting this is in the
years before the Great War big mountain
had been the home to the brightest minds
of the 21st century scientists of vision
were drawn to the facility to tackle the
greatest technological challenges of the
era they sought to create a new world
fueled by technology for the benefit of
all mankind hmm sonic emitters space-age
alloys DNA hybridization a force field
particle research autodoc advances in
cranial cardiac in trauma surgery the
hopes and dreams of a century became
realities in the electronic edges of
big-mountain the nucleus of this
research was the dome a huge stone
facility that held the labs of every
science known to man hmm ok it was a
think tank where no problem could not
the psalm where no question could not be
answered the Great War brought a new
energy to big-mountain and its
scientists although sheltered from the
front lines the scientists waged their
old war fighting their battles at the
atomic level but innards equations and
calculations marched endlessly across
chalkboards and computer terminals
toward one solution winning the war for
years the mines and computers of
big-mountain were ablaze of trajectories
weapon schematics and nuclear theories
hmm the problems began to outpace the
solutions first geometrically then
exponentially as the war esque
lated so did the questions but all the
night of October 23rd 2077 the
scientists received an answer that put
all their questions to rest occurred in
the aftermath big mountain silent
experiments went to sleep their creators
slowly dying in the new world that had
been left behind and the great stone in
the middle of the big empty lay
untouched filled with countless
technological wonders wonders that in
the end had been answers to the wrong
question acha okay well let's say what's
another hall I like like titles he'll
strangely happier faint surgical scars
are on your head chest back and anus
okay welcome to the Big M day oh yeah Oh
for is that good cuz that's 15 I'm out
okay okay um
n'ap speech
Oh dad this
I'm gonna go Shaq West